the Joe Rogan experience you should tell
him some of the stuff that you've read
that you don't know is true I mean if
the the stuff was true about the
propulsion stuff I mean anyway he well
what have you run what what you saw - um
you know what are you talking about
spill the beans Bob I got a poke the
bear here get some more liquor in you
the well I mean the again the the only
thing I could verify was what I had my
hands on they were you know there was
talk of weapon systems that there were
different projects project Galileo
project sidekick was supposed to be
weapon applications of the craft project
Looking Glass had to do with time any
effects of time in the craft now I don't
think we're not talking about making a
time machine like in science fiction but
we're talking about you know small
distortions intentional distortions of
time and how that can be used you know
as a not as a well it was part of a
weapon program how are you informed in
this phase again where there's just the
small briefings that I read but again I
don't really like to talk about those
because I don't have any information on
him and it was just you know small
briefings they told commander flavor
that what he saw might have been a time
dilation and not well because gravity
affects time you know space time I'm
sure you've heard of that and you know
what what commander Faber saw as he was
in the f-18 approaching it he said it he
described it as a ping-pong ball in a
cup and shaking it back and forth it was
moving that fast now obviously if
there's anything inside there it's gonna
be battered to hell but you know my
point was was that well one of two
things either there's a gravitational
envelope in there which negates any
inertia effects or you are seeing
through a gravity distortion field so
you know just like you're looking at a a
hot Highway and you see you know an
optical distortion going through there
well the same thing happens in gravity
and the
F may not actually be moving like that
it may just look like it because you're
seeing you can only see it through the
field so it may be making much more
gentle moves I'm not saying that's it
but it has to be one of the two and the
thing shows up 60 miles away they
noticed it on radar 60 seconds after
left commander flavor but it was at his
cap point which is the next point he was
destined to go to 60 miles away and in
60 seconds on radar the same object ends
up there so it's going a mile a second
no they I think the radar just picked it
up in 60 seconds yeah it could have been
there instantly but yeah we don't know
the cycle nobody knows that's all things
also it cycles like radar cycles doesn't
sweep you know it scans around it it
random place the spy one does the really
cool doesn't do the whole loop anymore
right the point the point is though that
the craft moved to his next location
before he knew where his next location
was going to be Jesus and that I mean
that's well documented so that that's a
pretty shocking piece of information
what's fascinating to me too is that you
were discussing this the the way this
reactor worked and that these things
were not really connected no nothing is
connected there's no wiring at all that
freaks me the [ __ ] out charge your
iPhone you know yeah
yeah yeah I mean that's the that's a
medic yeah I know again but that's just
simple electromagnetic induction revenue
Tesla the scientist had this concept of
right that's what yeah yeah that's what
I'm talking mean Franklin on the worse
and he wanted to send wireless
electricity through the sky and
Westinghouse was like get the [ __ ] out
of here with that like when anybody
could just pull electricity yeah this
cam meter yeah they couldn't they
couldn't we just talked in the car right
over there trying to chill them out you
know we're talking about Tesla you know
you couldn't be meter didn't have it all
that down so it's funny bring it up yeah
that that mean who knows what would have
happened in terms of innovation
had he been allowed to go forward with
that well we probably wouldn't have
computers you think yeah I'm pretty
positive well I mean forget about
microelectronics well this is dumping
huge amounts of electromagnetic energy
in the air and yeah we'd be able to
wirelessly turn on our lights but
there'd be no radio communication the
interference would be something we could
would be overwhelming it would induce
electric currents and anything with a
small wire on it so integrated circuits
transistors would be disintegrated
before they were even you know tested
for operation so it would destroy us up
yeah it would have stopped us dead we'd
have it'd be great you can turn lighters
on and heaters from all over the place
with no wires but it would stop modern
electronics and this leave Hakeem
dependent on it it would almost be like
our dependence on fossil fuels although
its destructive it's very difficult for
us to get off the nipple it would have
changed the course of how we developed
which is so interesting when you talk
about if a civilization of the star
system didn't even start with fossil
fuels they had 115 naturally on their
planet and they're like cool
anti-gravity is pretty awesome well the
fact that they I think it's important
that that actually happened yeah it
might have been stopped in its tracks
for a reason whoa and it's just it's I
think it's incredibly difficult for us
to imagine technological progression
under another timeline other than the
one that we've experienced yeah that's
difficult if we imagine what this alien
race must have been like and now I mean
God just just to be able to see
something like I mean obviously we've
seen it in different life forms right
like we see the life of certain beetles
in comparison to the life of certain
fish very very different existence very
different life cycles octopus yeah
octopus I mean we see all these
different variables in terms of
biological entities on earth but we
don't see it in terms of technological
innovation as we're the only one that's
intelligent that can innovate we we have
intelligent creatures but they're in the
ocean the only other thing that are like
us are dolphins and orcas and whales and
they don't have the ability to
manipulate their environment and
subsequently
because they don't have the ability to
emit and manipulate their environment we
put him in fish tanks and we let get in
the tank do some tricks right you know
the only thing he saw in the craft if we
were considering Bob's story the only
thing that you he saw in the craft that
he related to it looked like a human
could make was this honeycomb hatch and
I always loved that because you're like
obsessed with this thing that you could
recognize a rate yeah I I only focus on
that because it was the one thing that I
understood how it worked what was it and
it was it was the access to the level
below and it was well you know if you
take you have a six-pack of beer and you
take out the cardboard dividers mm-hmm
set it on the table you can put a lot of
pressure on the top but if you push it
from the sides it collapses flat hmm so
it was something like that in a
honeycomb shape that was essentially
some sort of sheet metal and you could
walk on that in the upper layer but if
you took the corner stuck your finger in
and pushed it collapsed and made a an
entryway hmm so I thought that was a
really unique I had never seen that
before and it was the only thing in the
crap that made absolute sense to me as
it ha we can make that and all that is
as a hatchway was there any discussion
about the materials that were used to
make the craft I'm sure there was but
that was a metallurgy division had
nothing to do with us she never got a
not even the slightest briefing I don't
even know if it was metal or it was
ceramic it's I think it there's a fine
line between the two
[Applause]